I'm British astronaut Tim Peak and I'm
going to be talking about some of the
most iconic moments in the history of
human space flight for Wired behind each
of these photos is a different story
about humans in space missions being
just seconds away from failure breathing
again thank the lot secret
codes and taking crazy risks well just
because we
can I guess we should start at the
beginning the first human in space Yuri
Gagarin strapped into his VTO one
capsule there
inside that spacecraft there is a code
that is secret even to Yuri himself Yuri
didn't have any control over the
spacecraft at all it was fully automated
by a computer system and mission control
code 125 would allow manual controls but
only in case of an emergency there was
so much fear in the Soviet Union about
defection that the code was hidden from
the cosmonauts themselves and they were
only going to be told about it in the
event of an emergency but actually
several people did tell Yuri the code
secretly before he flew so he knew what
it would
be what you may not realize is that on
the front of his helmet there he's got
the letter cccp to represent the Soviet
Union it was painted on at the very last
moment the Soviets realized this iconic
moment there was nothing to identify him
as a Soviet Cosmonaut so one of the
engineers grabbed his helmet and painted
those letters on that paint is still wet
right there in his capture
[Music]
the launch didn't actually go completely
according to plan Yuri went into a
higher orbit than was expected they
didn't bother telling him about it there
really wasn't much he could do about it
anyway and he didn't land in his
spacecraft either the VTO ejected the
cosmonauts out and they actually
parachuted back down to earth and upon
Landing Yuri was greeted by a very
shocked farmer who he asked to call
Moscow Valentina terova first female to
fly into space actually this was part of
the Space Race the Soviets had got wind
of a woman in space program over in the
United States trying to see if any of
the physiological differences between
women and men would create an advantage
for flying female astronauts into space
no surprise they didn't just pass it
they actually performed in about the top
2% of their male counterparts when the
Soviets got wind of this program they
thought well we're not going to get
pipped at the post and so they went for
their own selection process and
subsequently flew Valentina terova as
the first female in space and the women
in Space Program it was just a study in
fact it was over 20 years until the
first American woman flew to
space we've got Ed White here the first
American to do a space walk the United
States had wanted to be the first nation
but 10 weeks earlier Alexa leonov had
gone outside of his spacecraft and and
done the first ever space War and it
wasn't without risk leonov's space suit
expanded so much in the vacuum of space
he had to depressurize his own suit to
get back in the United States realized
that their first Space Walk better be
something a little bit more impressive
than just opening the hatch and poking
your head
out I feel like a million
dollar also you may not know that on his
space walk he lost a glove with the
hatch open to the capat sh look like a
theral this happened several times
sense like when this $100,000 toolbox
floated away from this NASA astronaut in
2008 oh great the tool bag circled Earth
over 8 months before burning into a
fireball and destroying itself over the
Pacific Ocean the other thing both of
them realize is that there are no
handrails at all on the outside of these
capules they're floating around on
umbilicals here out in space at one
point Ed was wiping himself over the
windshield of the cap and his crewmate
inside was kind of saying hey you know
get get yourself off my
spacecraft possibly one of the most
iconic photographs in the history of
human space flight if you zoom in then
you'll actually see Neil taking that
photograph reflected in the gold visor
of Buzz Aldren it nearly didn't happen
of course Neil nearly ran out of fuel
coming down to the
surface 5% the fuel got lower than it
had ever become in any of the
simulations in any of the train
scenarios bringing the land module down
to the surface it was kicking up all
this lunar dust Pi up dust and then it
wasn't able to even see his Landing
sight forward drif to the right little
was the Luna Landing module just going
to sink several feet into Luna dust were
the astronauts going to sink up into
their knees and not be able to actually
walk anywhere at all Neil had the cool
presence of mind to just continue on not
worry about the fuel so when the landing
module touched down the only way they
realize they're on the surface is when
the contact light came on contact light
and the engines were cut okay engine
stop tanquility base here the eagle has
landed you got a bunch of guys about to
turn blue we're breathing again thanks a
lot and you think wow you know to have
had such an incredible technical
achievement but actually still to have
had so many unknowns at some point you
have to do it you have to be the first
and these were the first people to have
experience that
this Photograph actually became known
just as the poster it adorned many
bedroom walls of teenage kids and and
younger who would just stick it up and
and look at that iconic image of a human
floating out there untethered the
feeling of exposure and vulnerability in
that suit the risk was palpable imagine
if one of those thrusters had just got
stuck in the on position as he was
maneuvering around around that would be
it game over Bruce would be off lost
forever into the cosmos and you could
arguably say well what was the point of
that what was the what was the higher
purpose perhaps there wasn't one this
was just like the jet ski of the uh
space Walking World just because we can
do it let's go out there and do it and
have fun another thing you may not
realize in this photograph is he was
shivering and and freezing cold so
although the poster looks like the most
Serene the most tranquil event ever for
Bruce at the time it was pretty hard
work Peggy witson June the 5th 2002 this
space walk really just shows how far
we've come now being able to perform 8h
hour very complex missions outside the
space station space went from being a
very competitive race between two
Nations to a very collaborative period
in low earth orbit and so having been
working apart during the Space Race
let's build a space station together
called the International Space Station
as we know it
today
this next photograph is Frank Rubio one
of the best things about space is
playing with your food and water frankly
and when you get a a bubble of water uh
in front of you it just makes you
realize how different the weightless
environment is we've gone beyond the
days of just building a space station
that we're spending huge amounts of time
now in space we're using it as a
microgravity laboratory and science
that's becoming more and more valuable
by the day as we realize what you can do
in
weightlessness
so fast forward to today and looking to
the future with emis 2 U not far away
now the first crew to return to Luna
orbit for over 50 years there's a little
bit of a space race starting again
though because Russia isn't part of that
partnership neither is China other
nations such as India having a very
Dynamic Space Program Landing a Rover on
the South Pole of the moon this new era
of space exploration as we move outside
of low earth orbit once more it's going
to be a very exciting 5 to 10 years
ahead